you said the other day that you don't
like to be thought of as underdogs
because you're a group of mba players
but you did have 60 to one odds to to be
here
what is the identity that you you do
like to think of yourselves as if it
isn't underdogs
a really good team
that's it a really good team
uh
not gonna say that uh
we're any better than anybody else but i
just don't think that we're underdogs i
don't
so what that nobody picked us to be here
um that's okay
i'm pretty sure nobody's picking us to
win either that's okay
um but we understand that we embrace
that
because at the end of the day we truly
don't care we just gonna go out here and
compete play together like we always
have and i'm see where we end up but at
the end of the day we're going to do
this our way the miami heat way and um
that way it's worked for us all year
long
all right i respect that enough stalling
enough stalin
who's stalling come on have some have
some courage
have some be like me have some courage
pick the heat you know you want to pick
the heat you know they won you over by
beating up on your celtics pick the heat
jump on this hit bandwagon i'm like mike
leech yeah you looking for a bandwagon
jump on this bandwagon i'm gonna tell
you this mike smith um
i learned i've learned a lot
during bubble ball
uh and one of the things i've learned
during bubble basketball nba version
is that the miami heat are a really good
team and i did not think that
coming into the playoffs uh when they
beat indiana in the first round it's
okay it's indiana so what big deal
short-handed indiana yep they got my
they got my attention with milwaukee but
not enough
uh i i was wondering what was going on
with milwaukee because you know i should
have i should have paid attention then
because nobody before that series
started nobody said you know miami heat
really match up well with the bucks
said no one ever no one said that
but they they dismissed him in five
games and they really
i know they beat the celtics in six
they really controlled the entire series
they controlled the entire series with
the celtics even the two games that they
lost they had control of that series
again that series was played on their
terms so i have much respect for the
miami heat but i'm not going to pick
them
uh to win i could tell
that whole that whole preamble told me
that you weren't picking
that was that was yours
yeah give them their props now you know
yeah and even though even though you got
to think this is disrespectful it's not
disrespectful
it would be disrespectful if i picked
the lakers in a sweep
but
the lakers circle the lakers are going
to win the series in five games
lakers and five lakers i've had a lot of
leakers in five lately i've heard a lot
of liquids uh why and i i kind of want
it to be i i respect miami but i really
want to get your attention so i'm
playing this out you can see this
playing out in real time
maybe to get your attention i say the
lakers sweep them
because i just i kind of want to grab
you by the lapels
and just let you know
that there's not only will the lakers
win this series i believe that's what
i'm about to say
there's no way the lakers can lose this
series
this lakers team is is
is very interesting to me i saw someone
i think from the la times
compare this to 2004 like this warning
shot hey the lakers in 0-4 they had a
star-studded team and they lost to the
pistons stop it there's no connection
what was the left of carl malone and
gary peterson yeah
exactly yeah it was just a it was a it's
a bad conversation
and yeah yeah i just think this lakers i
i can't pick against the lakers for many
reasons
one of them uh and this is probably like
reason number five but i want to get to
it first because we you would think
that the lakers are coaching themselves
or lebron james is coaching the lakers
i know eric spoelstra is a really good
coach
but so is so was frank vogel
and i think what vogel has done he's
done a really good job of
of blending into that team
having uh
some good assistant coaches including
jason kidd some co some assistant
coaches with high profiles high profile
players
and just kind of letting them do their
thing so i think frank vogel he's always
been a really good defensive coach going
back to his indiana days
the lakers are an excellent defensive
team right now
so he's a smart guy
but he's probably not even the smartest
guy on their team if you say that if you
look at the five smartest people in this
series
coaches included
two of them are on the lakers and
they're rajon rondo and lebron james
so you've got a really intelligent
lebron james and you got so you can't
it's almost unfair you got the smartest
player in basketball and the best player
in basketball the same guy lebron
there's no way he's going to lose the
series mike he has given
everybody in the playoffs
there's no way there's no way three
times four times
lebron and the lakers
everybody ain't no way i heard you
they've given everybody a game
okay there's there's there's one game
there's a vulnerability game that you
can take from the lakers
they've been playing
game one yeah they've been pretty
surgical and i think that beyond that
and i don't want to just play to the
emotions of hey it's lebron james he'll
figure it out no it's the way
lebron is playing here you're using uh
an analogy yesterday you used the stevie
wonder prince analogy
when you're talking about lebron and
michael jordan
all right let's make lebron
stevie
okay and this is his other championships
let's say his his second championship
uh that year they had the uh i think it
was a year they had the 27 game winning
streak if i'm not mistaken perhaps all
right
uh his second championship let's call
that his songs in the key of life
but this this team is definitive work
okay this is his
hotter than july
that it is not seen as one of his three
or four best albums but it's pretty good
if you go back and you look at some of
the releases there
you've got on this roster you've got
lebron second leading scorer and anthony
davis and so it's easy if you just look
at it on the surface it's easy to say
they're a two-man team but i think what
what i like so much about this lakers
team
is that
the roles are so defined
all over the roster
that there's no confusion about how the
team works i think it's a really good
team
it's not a star-studded team like the
it's almost like miami miami is a really
good team not a star-studded team
the la lakers are a really good team
with two first-team
all-nba players and i think they will be
able to so they'll look at they'll look
at miami
see a little bit of a mirror but they'll
go away from the mirror because at the
end of the day hey we got two guys that
you cannot match up with
and that's what we'll see in the series
two guys you can't match up with in
addition to some of the things that
you're talking about being together and
playing the right way
yes
they do that too and
mike lebron james you want to talk about
eric spoelstra who knows eric spoelstra
better than anybody
lebron who knows a miami culture better
than anybody lebron so i think they'll
be fine they'll be fine it's a five game
series
okay
uh the heat are better coached
they have they play better defense
their better shooting team
um
better defense where does that come from
where's the better defense coming i like
they're better defensive team they're
better is it
let's say you have the there's that
anecdotal or that this
is i like their defense better than the
lakers defense okay
okay i like i like i like their defense
better than lakers defense and what you
just did there i don't have the numbers
in front i don't have the numbers in
front of me but statistically i'd
venture to say they're a better
defensive team off the top of my head
somebody
some researcher somewhere will correct
me i'm sure point
correct is correct what you'll what
you'll find out by the end of this
series is that once again you will have
done the whole
more talented thing whether you realize
it or not
but the better team
is going to win this series the heater a
better team and and that that's that's
one i've already
and listen i don't know let me ask you
this though but i did you said some
earlier let's get off of the analysis or
if you want to call we just did analysis
let's get let's get off that for a
second yeah um
as a writer i do want to talk
emotionally to you for a second as a
writer as a as a columnist
sure
because there's a listen perhaps i'm
seeing this series through the prism of
maybe i am
getting caught up in the whether jimmy
butler likes to call him that or not the
underdog story maybe i'm just super
super impressed with what they did to
the top seed milwaukee who as it turned
out may have been flawed and miami was
perfectly capable of exposing those
flaws the celtics who weren't quite
ready for prime time i mean miami just
played better in that series so you know
perhaps my my outlook on this series
could be clouded by that i'm going to
acknowledge that um
what story just as a storyteller as a
writer
what story are you more invested in
because the because there's a weird
thing
as much as i can't decide you know
people always say like who's your team
like who do you root for i don't have a
team
i haven't had a team
really since i broke into the business
you know what i root for is i root for
stories
and
i love this group of miami heat
i love how relatively quickly they've
rebuilt themselves
since lebron's departure relatively
quick six years six years relatively
quickly typically teams don't come you
don't lose a lebron james in free agency
and then six years later you're back in
the finals i i just that's why i stress
relatively um okay
i the jimmy butler i i relate to jimmy
butler
i relate to a guy
being
viewed as
too intense
uh
and and and two uh you know
too tough
on people too demanding of people
but then
in the right set of circumstances with a
culture that embraces that kind of
commitment
now he's he's the glue guy he's the guy
that brings out the best in people so i
relate to that i i it's my spirit animal
jimmy butler in many respects right so
i i'm invested in these heat you know
these these into the lottery guys and
tyler hero and and and bam out of bio
and this this collection of guys but
then this is the weird thing this is the
weird thing
because i asked you the other day
uh you know whether cam it made the
patriots um fun
cool cool to root for fun yeah right
right
like man
i i find myself i mean i've always been
an admirer of lebron why don't you look
down behind myself
watch you no i'm just i'm just thinking
i'm just thinking no no no no no i said
look down look down can you see your
screen
can you see some numbers on your screen
i mean what did i say is that 0.7 that's
literally seven that's it and that's
that's for the season give me the
playoff number smartass which number
okay give me the playoff numbers that's
the this is the season they're a
different team right now and they're
working you know give me that playoff
number okay give me that playoff now
give me the playoffs oh and again you
want to play off just give me the
playoff numbers just give me a specific
playoff number that's for 2019-12 the
heat or a different team see y'all got
me off track throwing that
pay attention to what i'm saying okay
listen okay go ahead go ahead go ahead
get go okay don't panic that says 20 19
20.
postseason wait time out time out time
out time out okay if that's the
postseason put points aloud thank you
thank you there you go okay that's
supposed to be supposed to be great okay
fine no problem all right so anyway
you got it that's fine you got about
point seven seven one hundredths of a
point and that's just points a lot is
that that's points allowed per game give
me points per 100 possessions please
which sophisticated basketball fans
judge defense by nowadays okay just give
me that you want to do it i'll give you
a research assignment
the lower third
points per laptop
you arguing with gravity just give me
give me give me give me adjust it give
me adjusted field goal percentage per 48
minutes give me
okay listen
give me something
now i'm talking too long i just wanted
to tell you what i'm feeling though
is obviously the lakers it's a 30-second
trip to the finals lebron's tenth we
have a tendency as as a you know a
society as a sporting society sometimes
get tired of greatness and tighter
reruns we get you know remember the old
question is it bad for the game you know
for this team to be there every year to
stand the other so the lakers are back a
lot of lakers fans look at it as their
birthright and so they're not a team
that a lot of people even though they
are a national brand if you're not a
lakers fan a lot of people will be like
oh here we go not lakers fans again you
know they go with another another title
another trip to the finals but man this
this year especially with kobe with
kobe's legacy as as the as the
undercurrent or as the the overarching
storyline not just for the lakers but
really the league
is and there's a part of me that really
wants to see them get it done just for
kobe but also for lebron
you know i i find myself rooting for
both rooting for lebron and rooting for
the lakers which is not something i
don't think people typically do
root for the same old same old win again
is that am i making sense you know no no
it makes a lot of sense and i i i hear
what you're saying about jimmy butler
because i think that is a good story
it's not the best story but that's a
good story
from where i sit a guy who has never
been to the nba finals
and now he's going to be able to play on
this stage and get the credit
that he has never gotten the proper
credit uh
it's been pointed out we were just
talking about the clippers right and the
free agency
uh the chase for kawhi leonard and the
chase excuse me the chase for
paul george even though he wasn't a free
agent they were going crazy for those
two players jimmy butler was a free
agent
his team didn't bring him back
they loaded up without bringing him back
so i i do like that i like that
redemption story for him where he has
left places he's he's left some bad
franchises and now they're all worse off
without them